with its landmark Cathedral Eyeborg in
southern Germany is a good starting
point for a jaunt into the Black Forest
the university city is also famous for
the centuries-old system of water
streams trickling through the old town
Misha Gear studied German here and
decided to stay the region is so
attractive because the countryside is so
varied you can walk or cycle the weather
is usually great here in the south and
in the evening you can sit in the cafe's
have a drink enjoy the weather that's
what makes it so nice the blotter tile
valley is nearby for many it's the Black
Forest at its most picturesque
this building provided the backdrop for
the hospital series Schwartz filed
cleaning between 1985 and 1989 some 25
million viewers tuned in every week in
Germany alone to follow the stories of
chief of staff dr. Klaus Pinkman and his
team the 70 episodes were exported to 38
countries from Hungary to South Africa
the days when fans of the series would
flock to the glottal are over but they
still come from time to time and pay a
visit to Kaffee shell
let's chill used to be a hairdresser but
then he started selling souvenirs we had
some really good years but of course now
normality is kicked back in again but
we're still making a living off the
series fans who keep coming back to see
the clinic no city's our clinic pilgrim
just to the southeast of the glottal
valley is Lake ttz the gods pamper the
Black Forest with a lot of Sun so it's
great to go swimming in one of the many
lakes ttz is one of 30 lakes in the
Black Forest it's about 40 meters deep
in parts and it's especially popular
with families
with its dense tapestry of pines and
firs the black forests name originated
in the Middle Ages local crafts center
around woodworking and the most famous
export is of course the cuckoo clock
cuckoo clocks have been around since
1730 the Lombok and Fast Company in
Shona has been making them for more than
a century
it all began with this model it's called
a shield to climb and it's hand-painted
it's an original kind of cuckoo clock
but we designed a different model seven
years ago a modern one and now we make
very modern clocks one can do they all
chime this clock is 50 times larger than
your average cuckoo clock when it was
built in 1980 it was the biggest cuckoo
clock in the world
shown us traditional black forest hat
with its 14 red pom-poms is also larger
than life not far away in t-bag is
perhaps the most famous waterfall in
Germany it's more than a hundred and
sixty meters high the first bag is the
region's highest mountain
it measures 1,500 meters and is located
in the south of the Black Forest
I'm swats while passing I'm fascinated
by the fresh air good weather and
landscapes
I'm soft alpha mister guy sucks eylem
and nature you can hike and cycle here
there are many possibilities if you
climb up to the top of the tower you can
see over to the Alps on a clear day
Misha gear now works in a cafe in
Freiburg
it's an ideal place to end a summer's
day in the Black Forest